[Music]
this morning the one october committee
will meet to discuss a permanent
memorial
there has been a lot of community
engagement as the valley works to
remember the victims of that massacre
hector meghan joining us live near the
site of the route 91 harvest festival
with a look at the steps that are now
going to be taken to turn this into that
permanent memorial so important hector
it really is and it's a huge undertaking
so many steps this is where that future
memorial will go this is the site and
the committee now diving into the
artistic side of things going over
proposals talking with artists and today
they're also getting an update on
funding it's been a long process almost
a year since the first meeting the chair
of the one october memorial committee
says they want to make sure they do
things right so they're taking their
time members also want to hear what the
public would like to name this memorial
never before has clark county had to
build something like this the permanent
the permanent memorial will go at the
former site of the route 91 harvest
festival mgm resorts as we've been
telling you donated two acres of that
site located behind the las vegas strip
at the corner of reno and giles and that
is where we are live this morning so
again the meeting starts at nine o'clock
this morning that's happening over in
downtown inside the clark government the
clark county government center anyone is
invited to attend we'll cover it for you
and bring you the latest later on at
noon reporting live hector mejia
live local now
hector thank you i know you'll be
keeping an eye on that and of course we
want other people to have that option as
well so you can find all that coverage
it's on our website we have more
information on the memorial and of
course city council they do stream those
as well as the commission so you can see
those as they happen online